okay you guys ready
[ __ ] a boy what are you doing
in this week's episode i try to get the
first ever film i made nine years ago
screened on the big screen like an
actual cinema for a large audience but
like you know by now definitely not in
the conventional way
hey i'm dan mays i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
before getting into this video i'll be
giving away this original copy of my
first ever movie i made on this flash
drive that i used to sneak into the
cinema in this video to one person who
subscribes to my channel turns on the
notifications bell likes shares and
comments below letting me know that
you've done so
it's such a strange yet deeply
fulfilling feeling looking at something
that was once scribbled down in an
ideabook and then seeing the film
afterwards like this one remaking
godzilla by eminem out of hair ties
[Music]
or this one where i pranked my friend
casey with a fake shark behind you
it's a prank it was a prank this is what
it was dude
but now we're gonna do this idea which
is literally the fifth idea i ever wrote
in this ideabook on the 12th of november
2013 make a film for the big screen
remember the days well depending on what
generation i'm talking to here we're
going to the movies was a special thing
connecting with your family and friends
and getting pumped up watching through
this whole film without checking your
phone and then hanging out afterwards
with the full nerds or if you're one of
the naughty ones to go around back and
smoke cigarettes in the parking lot
there is something beautiful and
nostalgic about the cinema
what i'm getting at here is today for
the most part movies are watched like
this
[Music]
however seeing this idea that i wrote in
my ideabook made me realize how
important it is for me to fulfill this
dream of mine as a kid
and the film i would love to screen is
the first ever film i made for youtube
nine years ago called press play smile
as cringe-worthy as it is for me to
watch this now i know that back then it
meant to wilton so if you would like to
watch the full video press play smile
i've linked it below
the clear objective here is with no
meetups from my collaborators and
following with no promotion at all and
with no money i'd like to screen this
three-minute movie to a paying audience
without interrupting the movie they were
there to watch
most of the original cinemas in cape
town have closed down however there is
one cinema called the labia which is the
oldest independent cinema in south
africa it was opened in 1949 i used to
come here all the time as a kid and if i
could screen my first film anywhere it
would definitely be here
[Music]
so i met with redwan the projectionist
at the labia and told him i was making a
film about how projectors work which is
obviously [ __ ] my intent here was
purely to look for a way in
okay so what do you guys want to know
like absolutely everything about the
process
okay then follow me
i don't know when the last time i've
actually been to a cinema it just smells
so
like popcorn i can't put my finger on it
it's a good smile to have your film on a
screen like this
in front of an entire audience that's
the ultimate dream i've always wanted to
go into the projection room let's go oh
okay
this is really amazing
this is the projected itself what's the
process of getting
like a file on here maybe stick plug it
into the projector and then you download
it onto the server what file format it's
going to be like pcp can i write that
down yes just just for interesting yeah
easy
let me show you what to do
you didn't have to put in a password no
there's no pause with it okay yeah
that's interesting
he then showed me the rest of the
process as well as without knowing
unveiled the most crucial information
which is that on saturday yes yeah we've
got movies sewing in the cinema and the
smaller cinema on the other side this
means that once he presses play here he
then goes into the other projection room
that's interesting
success
the plan firstly i'd have to export my
youtube video which was only 720p back
then upscale it to 2k and turn it into
the right file which is dcp put it on
this usb drive then create three
hidden cameras mine will be worn like
this christian will be taking on the
role of a hardcore biker and liam will
he'll just be playing himself how is
that hidden it's like a cinema camera
and a popcorn thing
it's just sticking in your crotch
where's yours looking
so small yeah my one's definitely the
smallest mine's the biggest
the most non-invasive way to screen this
film is during the pre-roll outs so we'd
need to blend in with the crowd sneak up
the stairs make sure the projectionist
is in the other room and then slip out
his drive plug mine in with the text on
screen that says before watching this
movie he has something to make you smile
i click play then hide while christian
and liam use the undercover cameras to
get the audience's reactions i then slip
my drive out put his in and we're out of
there
okay you guys ready
yeah i feel pretty good about my
disguise but uh yeah yours is good
yeah that's ridiculous
[Music]
just as christian gets his ticket and
people started moving it there's no one
very suspicious
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh okay
[ __ ] gotta remember how to do this
[ __ ]
just gotta look and see if he's here
[Music]
um play
it's playing
okay you're gonna run down and get
audience reaction run run
[Music]
even though i made this film nine years
ago
it's still so nerve-wracking to screen
something
[Music]
oh there's a club there's a club
[Music]
deleted
and then we [ __ ] ran outta here
[Music]
[Music]
after going through this footage i've
realized that i've achieved something at
someone else's expense and that person
has read one and ethically i just don't
feel right about it
hello
how's it read one it's dan mace um i was
wondering if you possibly had some time
to meet yes yeah i do have time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i have something to come clean about on
saturday i snuck in here while you're in
the other projection room i
played a three minute video one of my
first ever videos um during the ad break
and it didn't interrupt the film when i
got back to the office i just felt like
i needed to tell you
so you've been naughty
yes i can show you
so i made this like this is the first
ever film i made nine years ago and this
is what we played
yes well
the phone gives you power from visits i
hope whoever watched it inside learned
something from it so you
okay i'm fine with it you're fine with
it i'm fine with it it was a naughty
thing you did yes and the fact that he
came to apologize and become clean you
know says a lot about him
ah
dude thank you so much for doing good
work thank you man you're welcome nobody
else try this better not
better not other than that don't forget
you're awesome brew and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you